hey guys Ryan right here and tonight I'm
gonna be watching the trailer for Metal
Gear Solid the phantom pain
I just saw the other one Ground zeroes
and now I'm going to check out this one
really excited for a Metal Gear saw
probably my favorite branch eyes video
game of all time there's some lutely
without a doubt my favorite games so I'm
stoked to watch this III you [ __ ]
Rock you make me want to drink your pee
pee as a disgusting run may contain
content inappropriate for little
toddlers anchors NASA that could you
know harm to the vessel which is stored
into anything on which report I got so
focused on reading it I didn't even
catch with it [ __ ] man
wow that looks horrible not an ostrich
that's not an ostrich different it's why
I thought that got some chills yeah my
man higher man tan
I really wish I knew what was going on
right now I should have played the
fourth game or the other one
whoa
nice
wow it looks so real Blood Diamond he
goes up against knives a lot dan this
looks the most cinematic
cheese's
oh I want to [ __ ] her
I don't know any of these people are
I know that one
this is gonna be [ __ ] epic man I
cannot wait
I love Metal Gear Solid's so much we're
not very good at sea
we're in diamonds from their ashes
take them into battle with us
shining light to our brothers in arms
even in death we are diamond dog
you
Wow dude what a [ __ ] prequel
oh sweet that was one of the best
trailers I have ever seen like ever
that was I'm [ __ ] speechless um
everything about it man like I did not
play the last two games so I feel a
little left out here but I I'm planning
on it because like I said it's like one
of the best stories ever it's one of the
best games ever I [ __ ] love the hell
out of this Metal Gear Solid franchise
now that I got time to play I'm gonna
start playing this [ __ ] and I want to
know what's going on I mean I kind of
understand but still it's it looks just
incredible I'm like every [ __ ] level I
love how it's like tying and everything
that's just so neat and it's it's just
it a man [ __ ] Kiefer Sutherland dude
you got a sexy voice anyway guys if
you're new to the channel subscribe want
to give some shoutouts Sean Drake can i
have a shout out please my user name is
Weapon X 18 Stryker well Weapon X 18
Stryker
here's your shoutout mother [ __ ] I've
seen so many trailers tonight this would
be the 14th trailer I've seen tonight I
need to find something else to do Sean
Drake that sounds like a rapper's name I
think those are two rappers names so
yeah I know a lot about rap clearly it
is my forte Hawk mute oh six four nine
said why you know gimme shoutout I hate
you I unsubscribe now I'm just kidding
unlike some people haha great bit don't
know why I did that horrible Chinese
accent very racist impression that fit
well here's a shout-out Hockney no 649
you got one back off now buddy cuz it's
yours
and there's this really beautiful girl
named Natalia saw some oil OVA um
developing your obsession with her
really creepy obsession
she said Ryan I love your reactions just
she's only comments at once and she's a
beautiful blonde just wanted to say hi
and I love you Philippi Olli Viera
you've been wanting to shout out for a
while here it is finally get it you
finally get it I'm so happy that you
finally got this shout out you've been
wanting it now you earned it let you
just do things to me craziest things
craziest